[Music]
and the best new artist is
the grammy goes to alicia keys
oh my
gosh all right i'm stuck for words let
me just say thank you for this this girl
is on fire
it was 20 years ago when a speechless
alicia keys stepped on the scene nearly
sweeping the grammy awards winning five
out of six trophies including best new
artists
[Music]
one of the most special was the song
grammy for the song of the year i feel
very very proud of fallen
for how it's just transcended
race and religion and color and all
boundaries it's really made me proud i
introduced alicia keys and she did
fallen
and i looked
around
to watch the reaction
and these very very knowledgeable peers
were just so affected
by the stunning beauty and originality
the way that felicia plays classical
music leading into that hip-hop intro so
it was very it was a lifetime memory and
we pulled it off
it was a long way from the little girl
in the mirror
when you were growing up did you
practice an acceptance speech like in
the mirror you know with the cone
well a little bit maybe if the door was
closed real tight locked it you know my
pretended a little bit what'd you say oh
they're going to try to make me do it
[Music]
but before the winning streak eti got to
hang with alicia backstage in 1999 at
the mtv europe music awards she was just
18 years old this is good for the you
know upper body bicep curls
strength the
winning of awards is
very good you know it's definitely it
feels nice and it's a great feeling but
i think you know the most important for
me is you know being able to perform
live
[Music]
fast forward to the artist who now owns
15 grammys and an empire
what's it like for you because i
remember meeting alicia he's the
musician and now it's alicia keys the
mogul and hey
hosting grammys and doing all these
things
the evolution is really incredible i
think that it's really powerful and
naturally we're all here to continue to
grow and to find our way into new things
you know music is definitely my core
business moving into film television
books and even other businesses beauty
and lifestyle and as women you know it's
very very important that we're at the
seat of our tables and that we're at the
seat of all these tables and the mom of
two is also pulling out a chair for her
11 year old son egypt teaching him how
to sing and play the piano
if he ends up making it to music's
biggest night as an artist someday maybe
his mom could host again oh that this is
like a one time thing
that's what she told et in 2019 but then
in 2020 she became the first female
music star to emcee the show twice
ms alicia keys uh what made you come
back for year number two of hosting the
grammys no idea what was i thinking what
am i doing here i said i wasn't coming
back what happened i don't know now what
happened is
it was so good
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you learn hosting last year so
learned you have to be really close with
the teleprompter person that person is
your best friend
ace homie and if they're not on your
team it's detrimental it was ridiculous
you said one and done last year you came
back this year do you have another one
in you because i'm well listen you've
proven now that you can do it that's
true
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave that one
unanswered
[Music]
you